адель trout валу
петля і вже 20 ракет просив у
університеті штутгарта та студенти мої
будні архітектури це місце буде якесь
едельтраут завжди підібралася її робота
а шпакова на ви підкова знайди знав
освячую ікону я хочу мувік на ті ж
посади за рубля я benji
спирту цуценя думала c помив до вона потим
дорослими лощоод так не практикується
на рак і спробуй звук і на вас з
великий а нам а голосячи вранці від і
поясними в університеті
алаві ніс наш вигляд до відразу мило ще
цінності рб але і для dos ще ти не спиш
ночами
that is no на твою психіку ти
підкоряєшся наповнити сильну і за
намагаєшся б ч я сру було неправильно
один правильно
ще шківах подивився цій
нас правді едельтраут мої ви ще
кваліфікацію у неї магістерської ступні
задуму має і грубить караючого
зарплатню ступаю на майя теж вала
виріж лапід їжу суду думах тис
рівної оплати протий антон борисів
вершина земна сміялася і мовляв ніхто
не судіть від робота дотсом дарма вважається
злом табу
червоний і не бивши на мочалів стирчать і
правого віку
саме Петро мати заміна прямо з кулак
і цю роботу давати едельтраут
університет штутгарта пояснюю ризницю
зарплаті темп микола людина п'є пиво
автором книги треба до своєї позиції
адміністрації університету посилаєте на
нормативні акти це інструкції рахунок
оплати брати i can be so nice to lose
що зрозуміло для однак і службами про
порядку
ми ви пробували все можна вишнях ще
гривня ти зарплати я ще й суд скажи ще
три дні то я їх не став kein і можна тієї
університет штутгарта малий ще може у
Труби то й прута німецькі суди в
позу вали залишимося грубих федеральний
суд не матч він і
ти хлопець праворуч будди розряду ти
європейський суд справлю ден і у
страсбурзі
щеня до того ж тільки я хочу продовжувати
обороти ся можна до цих пір і змін